speaking about the world being uh
completely [ __ ] uh Alex Jones turned
on Q Anon I I know almost it's a very
tough mat they had a rough marriage they
fought it and they fought it out for
years uh and eventually we just knew
someone was going to leave someone
tried to leave him a few months ago oh
so yeah it was just staying at someone
else's house the car wasn't in the
driveway
um yeah well the thing about Q Anon that
makes it a lot of fun yeah is it's kind
of a make it up as you go along I've I'm
a drug addict right so often my lies
aren't planned they're in the moment a
lot of what I do on the podcast a lot
you know it's only in the moment I'll
have an idea what I want to talk about
and I rant and I go and I've been like
stoned and I show up at home and my
parents are like what's going on there
was 50 on the mantle now it's not there
and I'm like
well and I gotta make something up on
the spot right I've been you know are
you drinking again no I'm not and then
you gotta have a well you were gone for
two days no one knows where you are and
somebody said you left your car well I
was well this is I was at a sales
conference and I left my car I flew to
Phoenix like yeah I understand what that
is Q Anon is an ever-evolving conspiracy
theory where the events are happening uh
in the past in the present and in the
future it's kind of hilarious every
conspiracy theories at Kennedy something
like that there's a lot of Truth in that
or all truth but at the end of the day
it's like you're looking back from
thirty thousand feet analyzing little
things that have already happened Q
anon's like so I think Alex is kind of
like I'm a little tired of the constant
evolving nature of that conspiracy
theory yes so he's not a fan of like the
Jazz that is queuing on so they're not
because they're improvising they're
improvising Alex is like hey man I I was
on board a little bit but at the end of
the day it's getting a little annoying
because it can turn on you eventually
you become part of the conspirin Jersey
right still Alex's controlled opposition
that's what they'll say eventually you
because Q Anon just eats things so it's
a conspiracy that just eats things the
minute you start to say hey man maybe
that's not it'll just eats you and go
you're in on it everyone's in on it
everyone's a satanic pedophile everybody
everyone that questions it is uh eating
children and you go wait a minute that
seems illogical and but now there's not
enough children
and I think Q anon's over now
unfortunately uh
um because for these people but I think
fortunately for them they're gonna have
to find a new hobby but I think it's
over now because even the best Q Anon
people now are starting to go hey man
this might not be going down the way we
thought yeah but they've literally gone
as far as to saying that like Biden and
Trump switched faces Trump's actually
still the president except Biden's yeah
you have to be a real [ __ ] now you got
to be real stupid now it's at the end
like when it was cool like when the app
seen stuff happened Q Anon was like it
was party at you yeah and then when the
hunter bite laptop stuff started to
happen they were like dancing like it's
time
and then
Biden wins and they're like wait whoa
and it's just like it's the day after
the party q a if you ever went to a
party in high school or college Q Anon
right now is the day after the party you
wake up it's it's 12 noon the sun is
hitting you in the face you're hungover
there's a statue of disgusting beer and
cigarettes all over the house you're
like what the [ __ ] happened here I gotta
get out of here I gotta bacon egg and
cheese that's what Q Anon is they gotta
sober up get out of that house get a
bacon egg and cheese and go man we were
[ __ ] whacked we were high dude I
thought Nancy Pelosi was eating children
for four years and that Donald Trump was
going to put her in Guantanamo Bay yeah
wow that was
because I mean it's interesting that
people had to do that after the 60s they
were like yeah I just did a bunch of
acid and I lived in a Ranch in Malibu
and [ __ ] everyone I ever saw and
they're like I thought that was the way
the world was gonna go and I followed
some Shaman guy some Guru who just
wanted to [ __ ] me and 10 other people
that were living there and uh we did
that for three years apparently we never
created the Utopia we thought we're
gonna have and now I'm back working here
you know at Allstate Insurance and we
have great policies and we'd love you to
come in the office so we can break them
down for you it all ends folks all the
love all the [ __ ] ends but it's fun
they had so much fun Q Anon was hard to
get mad at because they were this was
all they had yeah
they were quite good at it and they were
good at it and they and and and and it
was a lot of desperate people but they
were also Rich idiots there's also like
dumb rich people and you that those are
like the saddest people in queue because
it's like they should they have the
resources to do other things yeah but
they're just a love cue they're like I'm
just into this and I'm like you're rich
go do something how incurious are you go
to the Amazon vote Bird walk I don't
know but they're you know so play golf
it's sad but they're like done now I
mean they're they're oh it's over oh so
you think this is the uh I think
everything's ending my whole thing is
that trumps out Q anon's over the
quarantine's gonna end everything's
gonna go back to something that's more
recognizable I think that are you
optimistic about the 2021 and what in
certain aspects I have optimism and then
I have I have short-term optimism and
long-term pessimism okay meaning that I
think in the short term things can get
better I think long term because there's
so many forces that are out of our
control that are revolving in ways I
barely understand that are carving up
Society it's going to be very tough long
term to be completely optimistic like
hey it's gonna be great it's gonna be
good forever but short term I think yeah
there's quarantine will end things will
get better the economy will get a little
better uh the constant Trump craziness
will die down a little bit that's my
hope and people can go back to focusing
on things that matter which is you know
the things that are near you and close
to you yeah the humans around you humans
around you not
Nancy Pelosi I have my I have uncles
that talk about Nancy people I'm like
you've never met her you'll never meet
or shut up yeah and I I have a belief
that this kind of local love and
kindness that you naturally can have for
human beings that you actually know can
be expanded at scale through the social
networks that we use that we build that
Twitter is currently failing at that
miserably that would be great but that's
if we were able to increase the love
through the social networks that would
be great it feels very hard too
it's a worthy challenge